you're joining us now with more reaction
the host of war stories Colonel Oliver
North let me let me pick up with what
dr. Gorka was saying it's interesting to
watch the media reaction to the
President and not only wanting free
trade but also wanting fair trade and
saying that there's got to be
reciprocity knowing this president as
well as I do you know him well Colonel
North he's the consummate constant
negotiator and what he's doing is well
he exempted Canada and Mexico and he
said oh and every other country is open
for renegotiation the whole thing is of
negotiation and similarly here he he
obviously never wanted to go to war with
North Korea but nor was he going to give
an inch to Kim jong-un and his
dictatorial practices in his
intimidation and his supposed show a
force with his missile launches
so do you suppose that there's a rapid
translation of the art of the deal being
made into Korean right now I would tell
you the the comment made by by Senator
Graham was spot-on if he thinks that
he's going to go into this conversation
and try to pull something over president
Trump Trump's eyes or his head he's dead
wrong look at here's the other part of
this that no one's seen yet for over a
decade the Iranians have been paying for
the North Koreans to act as their R&D
facility for so that the deal that was
done isn't going to show somewhere and
that mccr evolutionary guard corps is in
charge of the weapons of mass
destruction the nukes the ICBMs the
chemical weapons and the bio weapons and
they have been funding secretly
financial and tech support to the North
Koreans this is going to put them on
their butts the bottom line of it is if
this works and it's still a big if but
if this works it is going to make the
entire world safer because it's got just
going to stop the North Koreans it's
gonna stop the Iranians because they
can't get away with it doing it at home
even under the ridiculous agreement that
was made in Vienna you know is good news
but as well as anybody you understand
and you spent an entire life either
involved fighting on the battlefield
being with troops and heroes in the
battlefield and also you work that you
did in Iran when you are handed by
your government a suicide pill the case
god forbid you had to take it I'd never
understood the mentality everybody
praised Barack Obama he wins the Nobel
Peace Prize probably 150 billion in cash
and other currencies Bill Clinton
thought it would work with North Korea
and Kim jong-il it didn't work
he still has nuclear weapons and we got
to the point where we are today what is
it about the left in America that
doesn't seem to understand you cannot
bribe a murdering dictator regime son
years ago you and I were on the radio
together talking about Madeleine
Albright doing the Macarena in North
Korea because the deal that they had
done in 1994 that deal is what got them
to this point today that in the help of
the Iranians and what's now happening
with this with this arrangement if this
works and I pray that it does it's not
only going to stop what's going on in in
the Korean Peninsula it's also gonna
have a very positive effect in the
Middle East because this is a major
setback for the Iranians they've been
using the Assad regime and the North
Koreans to do things that the rest of
the world is looking the wrong way while
the Iranians are doing it this is a
major blow there's no downside goal can
you tell me if all right sanctions
continue the joint exercises continue
you have a promise before May that
release from now until May is not going
to be firing any missiles or test firing
them what's the downside I don't see
inside is the downside is that this guy
comes from a family line that does
nothing but lie they've lied repeatedly
now for decades about what they're doing
and what they're not going to do the
minute they like the minute the deals
take it off the table understood and
hopefully he will understand that that's
why that little light-hearted comment
about art of the deal if this guy
understands what he's up against and
sitting down at a table somewhere in the
world opposite Donald Trump he had
better mean it when he's saying I'm
going to denuclearize by the way it'll
be magnificent for the people of Korea
be magnificent of the world right this
is this is a major step in the right
direction and I go back to what we
always say trust but verify and you're
never going to get the a good deal out
of the press well not tomorrow not
morning it's all going to be bad to give
everybody in the world five million
dollars and they still
sigh some yeah all right colonel safe
home good the brief yeah